yeah hello and welcome to this video
this is some something I've not done for
quite a while on a video on my over the
board games something that I have want
to do often but then something like time
to prepare it properly and yeah this
time I thought let's go for it and do
one of my own games also game is pretty
fresh in my mind it's been played just a
couple of days ago in our local town
championships um and um it's been
interesting game so let's get going I've
got two white pieces here against see
the podium here here Sebastiaan van
Miren it's actually mistyped and I think
it's double e and and yeah I'm a pretty
huge favorite in this game level the
first round of the event but yeah they
turned out to be a really really
interesting struggle so let's get going
I played one idea three by the way this
is here or only chess and I think that
end of this border is pretty nice it's a
just out of a study and on the right
hand side you will see some of my
prepared notations then yeah I'll tell
you some details about them when you
when we scroll down how how I do them
and okay let's see neither three played
by me um this is my default move if I
don't really know anything better
yeah like sometimes if I have a specific
idea in mind I will play c4 deform or
sometimes deform now but Nadia 3 is what
I play if I don't have any particularly
great idea on UNT 6g 3 and b6
yeah so a Queen's Indian type of setup
um yeah certainly very solid clay option
G 3 I also play c4 in this position but
oftentimes I just decide to yeah as a
friend of mine often called it over the
house and then see what happens you just
do the four moves up to the C in Cairo
and then
site on the central information and yeah
Knight f6 here played the black most
obvious move I guess and here I went
before that move probably makes the most
sense in this position a new deform
which looks perfectly normal and is in
fact maybe not as precise as after c5
you don't really have the opportunity to
play d5 as you would like to do and
probably after C form takes you get into
something that you don't want yeah you
don't usually want this early trade
where like will gain a tempo in their
pawn and then get this check in in an
awkward moment one after the Queen takes
black is not yet committed to having the
bishop on his heaven and this gives him
sometimes additional options for example
if a knight comes to c3 can play we
should reform so d4 is actually a little
bit less precise he and distribution see
if one is the better choice yeah now I'm
event with c5 transposing into a
symmetrical English this will oftentimes
start with one C form one c5 and so on
just a different move order here of
course but I can also play Bishop d7
castles and still delay the decision in
the center so c5 I play 93 and he goes a
six a six is a move that is played here
quite frequently like usually chooses
between Bishop e7
d6 or a six a six is usually the sign
that black is yeah going for Hedgehog
yeah with d6 later if he goes Bishop e7
in this position that will be ahead
shock most of the time but not
necessarily it's a bit more flexible in
that regard maybe there are many move
all subtleties a6 and yeah now white can
go mostly rook e1 d4 b3
I have for always
what extremely well would be three so
I'm sticking with this and now he
surprised me with the move Queen to d7
and that's a very early commitment of
the Queen
it is often good on c7 and hedgehog but
it's really early to put it down however
I couldn't really find anything great to
do now to get to review this yeah you
cannot refute this one but to and really
make it look bad in some way so I
decided to go just Bishop b2 as s was
planned Bishop to e7 yeah
and now and why it has a couple of
different ideas what to do in the center
you have to somehow make a decision
about the DND pawn that have not yet
moved if you play before in this
position black will take and now of
course you can take with the Queen which
is often seen but this idea starting
with B 3 and so on is usually for me at
least that's how I play it is to take
with the night and here I'd like to
build up something with III F for Queen
a3 this is what I want
however here like it is ready to play
Queen to b7 and this is a little bit
awkward yeah f3 is not a move I like to
play I mean the engine Lannister kind of
likes it at 3 d 4 and of course it is a
playable setup but that was not my
intention and I usually want to be ready
to play Queen f3 in such a situation and
trade Queens then bring the King to e2
and then play a for g4 and so on is the
idea so what I did is I delayed the
whole thing and played e3 first he
canceled
I went d4 now I was expecting him to
take Knight takes Bishop takes King
takes precision and after Queen to b7
Queen a3
cake sticks that we get an ending where
white is a little bit better
it is nothing great really have to admit
that with white has a little bit of
something on the deep pond and the b6
porn sometimes if black plays d5 he also
has to be wary of the somewhat weakened
c6 square this is all very very little
yeah but the Hedgehog is a pretty good
opening it's not easy to get anything
anyway
in the game he surprised me by playing
these six yeah it looks a little bit
like you see the moves perform they
actually on the board but I don't really
see how to avoid that maybe I can
somehow obscure the move list but I
don't know how he played t6 just yeah
not reacting through the deform this is
actually an interesting move because it
asks wide now what to do with the center
of formation the most obvious choice is
d five-year lettuce then what white um
definitely would like to play in order
to somehow punish what black did however
after he takes I don't have the typical
idea of moving the night and then take
care with the piece because the early
Queen c7 has covered the b7 Bishop so
here you can take and has an extra pawn
that wouldn't be possible with the Queen
on b8
I mean the computer actually gives right
some compensation but yeah it's really
not great and and if I just recapture
the normal let's say I was worried about
b5 yes the engine still likes white but
I wasn't so sure during the game
now um b5 in already for black he has an
idea to b6 maybe put some pressure here
and Ruki aids bishop f8 g6 he can
probably yeah play some sort of Ben Oni
maybe also move there
six nightly ballistics and some sort of
Benoni where I wasn't sure if my pieces
with although she and kettles I really
rightly a correctly positioned it might
be not bad for me but it wasn't
something that I totally liked so I
decided to play wedding move look-see
one and then see what happens
yeah maybe he takes after all he did
just kept the tension that was really
interesting I mean just keeping the
center and waiting for y22 to make some
kind of commitment and okay again I can
play d5 but if I wanted that I would
have done it self remover Liam I decided
at the end to play Queen to e2 just
keeping the tension and potentially go
for the movie form u3 to reform and here
black has some choices we see a game
here in the annotation Akopian pankratov
this is I think a rapid game from the
Berlin repertoire Championships that
Punk right off played 94 this is a very
standard way of playing this simply
stopping white from advancing any
further and I probably would have played
with ft-1 and now black as the computer
suggested probably take and now has to
think about playing Bishop before or not
this is often an ABN 95 could funny
technically and by the engine but it's
still not a bad mood or black and simply
stay and away proceedings and the thing
is that White's the best at what you can
do is go before and then we get the
Hedgehog and what he played is also
perfectly okay to droopy eight and now I
played in the form allowing the
transformation into into C takes night
eggs to a full Hedgehog and surprisingly
he did not do that I think black should
simply take and then play a dragon
natural move then computers you see it
likes white in this position it gives
right 0.5 0.6 but this is a typical
computer has been based on the extra
space of course the space needs
something but we know that in magic
blacks solidity is extremely difficult
for Y to handle you don't really have
much ideas for Y to do to wind quickly
use that space quickly you rather have
to maneuver yeah I probably would have
played that in a pretty slow way if 3kh
to maybe try at four at some stage you
have to really be careful about the pawn
advances for example if you are
completely it like not patient at all
and play something like that like might
quickly push me five at some point yeah
immediately probably Knight f5 is a
problem I'm 95 excellent gifts given by
the comm okay but then any air form you
have to be where that be five might open
up book again screen so this is what I
expected but he surprised me by playing
the move e5 and simply stopping right
from going any further
um yeah g5 I think is the move that now
gives white an opening advantage and
White has two main choices taking on
playing d5 I relatively quickly played
d5 there's some this there's some more
than one reason for it and the caption I
assume details but that X is move and
the capture is also a bit better for y
the reason is that I'm quicker with
putting something on d5 in fact the
engine suggests to play 95 immediately
and also this night can be relatively
quickly connected to
two light squares something like this
looks better than black maneuvering with
his knives black and try night f-86 but
this is not that easy to do because when
you make moving out of eight you neglect
the color of the e5 pawn so I think
white is somewhat better in this
position as well however white is also
better in the game continuation after d5
this is basically saying okay you're
playing a check then only this is a
check when only formation where black
has the bishop Queen and placed on the
are not really the best squares and it
takes a bit of time for him to get f5
going in some kind of way because this
f5 push would be the only active
possibility that black has in this
position and I failed again this is
difficult to achieve I have nine h4 for
example looking at the square or
sometimes Bishop h3 so I was thinking
okay I've got more space and black spot
black pawn Davis look weird so a little
difficult to do b5 would be the other
pawn a break but then it's not easy to
play either simply because with the
pieces placed as they are he cannot
cover b5 that often so that is possible
and even if it happens it's not really a
big issue so I felt like the space
should give me something the end it is
like giving me roughly one form okay let
play Knight f8 opening up this idea and
maybe bring the light to g6 there's
something that you can actually argue
about because the knight on g6
oftentimes is misplaced due to the pawn
being on g3 and night here mostly it
looks at protected squares on the other
hand you can argue that with Lex limited
space you need some place for this piece
and d7 is probably standing in the wave
you hear it's an interesting choice what
and I played the move Bishop h3 I can
put it on the board by the way this text
here why my slippers are white is better
this is similar to some evaluations here
this is from the automatic analysis of
chess players and just as you can do
this tactical analysis where you let the
engine check every move for let's say
three four seconds and then it doesn't
auto commentary on it and this is what I
actually often do if I get a fresh game
and then once at least an idea if I
blundered something I would invest the
two or three minutes just start the
automatic analysis and I don't know yeah
do something in the kitchen then return
and I see okay there was no obvious
blunder in there and then starting from
that like let's say rough commentary I'm
going to do my own work on it so some of
this is actually from the computer and
not by me and so Bishop age 396 is what
you played and the move Bishop age three
is actually something that is not
totally clear choice and it has a couple
of ideas I'm taking more control over at
five and basically invite the trades
with Bishop c8 and on the other hand I'm
trading which I don't like to do with
having more space why definitely has
more space the upside is the bishop on
g2 um is only light square and I've got
five pawns on nine squares this is not
such a big deal due to my space but
still it's not the greatest of pieces I
don't really mind the trade all that
much and what really encouraged me to do
it is that I actually trade off with
Bishop c8 and you really know that
Bishop c8 will probably happen with this
traded his light squares f5 in
particular our week and maybe it makes
f5 more difficult to play so I think
it's a move that you can play it's not
96 and here played the move Knight to e1
mmm yeah it's a it's certainly possible
the knight on f3 is not ideally placed
that's clear
the question is where to put it I was
thinking the knight is best on d3 and
this is where Yan ended just just a
couple of moves later
d3 often times is it good square for
this piece we can just put this on the
board by the way let's do it now you
won't appreciate z8l expected and I
think black is right in doing this yeah
the bishop 1 b7 is fairly useless so
we've got this trade and now I played 9
to d3 the knight is actually normally
well placed on d3 in a Benoni structure
because the two key breaks that white
has before and f4 are both about them
supported so this is a fairly normal
Square for it and I could have also
played 92 on IG 2 in order to place it
on in 3 this also would have been a good
square looking at f5 so that any future
black ideas to play a5 himself yeah it's
pretty much pretty much prevented and
you can jump there 5 maybe yourself also
reasonable I went to d3 and he played
Queen age 3 now it's a tempting move
where the Queen looks threatening on the
King side and what was possible here was
d5 maybe this is something that like
should have firm considered to play here
I cannot know well it doesn't don't help
that himself taking here does it help
the a file is open and then something
like this looks a bit strange to play
now it's maybe not terrible and and
suggests which
I don't really want to do that I would
have simply and yeah kept the tension
and played similarly to the game 91
that's what I played in the game data so
Queen f3 was played so now you have to
think about what to do on the kingside
with white now how to set this up I mean
black has a couple of pieces there and
you have to be a little bit on the
lookout that there isn't some some kind
of gear to tech brewing on that's on
that side of the board so I played that
three which is kind of yeah it has to be
played anyway in some way and it
supports a form that makes the knight on
c3 um yeah mobile it allows 9f2 to kick
the Queen out of the right position or
sometimes allow us also Queen G to gap
it said to move that as we play
basically no matter what yeah black and
played h6 and this is an interesting
move for night h7 yeah here I had a
longer thing because it wasn't totally
obvious to me what I should do I first
thought and I should probably play for
before this is them here's a possible
line to show what happens before trying
to open up the D file it is slow it's
really slow and way of playing
especially considering that my bishop on
b2 is misplaced now the bishop on b2
looks at this which doesn't make all
that much sense unless I'm able to bust
this open with their fourth with b4 I'm
saying okay I'm playing on the B file
and then this Bishop on the two really
is misplaced and yeah I'm expected here
something like this but I wasn't
entirely sure how good that is
I have the c6 square looks like but
whenever I go there after some Bishop f8
97 that can be traded
also note that will be six is probably
the weaker pawn
c4 is also weakened by this procedure
ultimately I found an idea that was too
tempting to not play and I actually saw
a pretty far head here and I'm happy
that I assessed it correctly I played
the move Knight to give one so how did
that move for come to my mind you know I
was looking at the pieces and I felt
that the knight on c3 doesn't do all
that much of course it is on this pawn
on the square so they defy this maybe a
little bit under control
still if black would play that I mean he
can do it in a two also hanging so it's
not like a total insurance the night
against b5 but I was thinking why not
try to get denied onto f5 isn't that it
would square okay it is a good square
quite clearly also night to f2 could be
an idea yeah but mostly f5 was on my
mind and I saw the following line he
played nine h7 but was it this was to be
expected
92 e3 by the way then Ian wants to play
before anyway and it's playable
it's not bad at all just that I had an
ad nm I was too tempted so 93 Bishop g5
and this is heading up a pimp
yeah and now comes the idea that I had
when I played 91
I played just 9f5 I was simply giving up
this exchange and this is what what
makes us an interesting game the
material imbalance that we now get yeah
black M has no real choice in this
situation here you have to see that I am
also threatening to play Knight f2
winning the Queen so we cannot just yeah
play any other move like here I have my
deaf to Queen h5 and now actually and
I don't default is actually still night
f4 but the queen is in an enormous
enormous trouble here in h4 comes into
mind many wants to play with c1 and then
later age 44
now I mean that looks really dreadful
also I mean taking the exchanges clearly
the critical choice so he took it and
now that's funny nine f2 is real threat
is the translation of that and yeah let
290 of two now will track the Queen so
if he now plays something like this I
will win the Queen it doesn't have any
squares so I anticipated 97 and now we
come to the most interesting and moment
maybe of the game um when I was on
playing 91 I anticipated this position
that this will happen and I saw the line
that actually happened in the game that
I played and what I did play is the
following I just want to show you first
what I did and then the alternative so
that you can compare and I played Knight
f Cho indisposition attacking the Queen
the Queen has no squares
besides h5 so he went to h5 now I take
the pawn that was what I had seen where
when I played ninety one the level will
be six for sure rook moved one Queen has
only h4 on g6 he went to h4 and now I
come back to x5 so what I do have is I
have one pawn for the exchange and it is
the fantastically good d5 protected
passer as this great night on f5 and if
it gets traded I will actually get and
this happened in the game the e4 square
this is what I saw when I played 91 back
when I played the night here that in
this situation with the exchange down I
would have plenty of compensation
however when we got here I started to
think about this a little bit more and
then I discovered an idea that was
extremely interesting and the idea was
to not play Knight f2 but rather take on
g6 first yeah what is the point of it
and ok taking the pawn is fairly obvious
actually but the problem is after Roop
EDH which is clearly the best move if
black is playing something else like
here I just win the second pawn and then
I've got two Center pawns for the
exchange en D pawn and it completes the
role of the game now plus look at those
Knight to f4 and so on it's fantastic so
this is the only move and now the
problem is that denied on d6 doesn't
have a good way back in the game I have
this g4 idea and then I had nine f5 here
this is not possible if I insert this
for example and he goes back my knight
really doesn't have many options there
something like this is not that great
you know he have an exchange down and my
compensation is not enough I'm actually
surprised that the engine still gives me
some sort of compensation until it
really looks looks bad so what is the
idea
yeah actually in this position here
white has two interesting options and
the first option is to it's actually not
right
then you have to the first move is
pretty clear that you play it but and
you have to take here on f7 okay get the
King takes I think that that he has to
do that there is not much choice and now
there are two options and I looked at
them both during the game and I can take
only five with check or player 4 F 4 is
the stronger move forward if I take on
in five
King d8 white now after tick-tock white
has sacrificed a rook a full rook for
three pawns so white has the d5 in for
three pawn for the rook and I saw this
position and I've held I could have
enough compensation the computer
actually does support this view I have
to have this stock Christian running in
the background and they're like 0.4
I've also checked it with some like 44
whatever I am from the engine cloud of
chess base it actually believes that
white is slightly better and this is
something that once you look at it a
little bit more you tend to appreciate
better during the game it is not that
easy for example white can just continue
this game I just make a couple of moves
to show just continue this in a fairly
slow fashion yeah you just say okay I've
had this team roller and I'm not in a
huge hurry to push it forward white will
push this forward slowly yeah even g4
can be sometimes played then black
pieces really don't do all that much
they're kind of sitting there and
they're mostly hoping you have to get a
counter sacrificing to stop the pawns it
is still not an easy decision
I mean you give up Luke for three points
and the compensation while being it's
obvious that there's something it's
still a tough decision to make in a real
game the second option was after the
capture to play the move at form
I also saw this and I felt that this is
probably the most promising of the whole
bunch when once we sacrifice on f7 and
yeah here black has two choices Mesa
mostly he can allow the capture on e5
here white can also take with the pawn
that's the difference to Knight takes e5
or you can take on their form if we look
the first option first King g8 here
after night eggs we would get the same
position type as you seen before the
three pawns steamroller and the Center
for the group or F cakes and this is
actually stronger here the course white
gets a pawn on to e6 that makes it
extremely dangerous for example look at
age 9 F 4 Queens 8b 6
and these pawns are fantastically strong
they completely divide the board and
they also are simply pushing forwards
yeah I mean this is quick d6
is coming now as you see the computer is
already liking white in this position
and one thing is clear defending this
position in an actual game for black is
absolutely hand action and I was rather
I mean I saw that this is pretty strong
I was rather irritated by black maybe
taking on a 4th that seems to be
stronger Knight takes Queen to d7 and
now 96 check King g8 Queen g4 let's
Teddy force and now we see that black
being a look woke up has some problems
finding move between g7 checkmate is the
problem it seems that he has to return
material already black cannot earn play
something like ok let's say this after
Bishop h6 um white is going to win this
very quickly in an attack so he has to
give it back
95 now C takes nd takes are both
interesting it's tough to say what's
better rating um but the center line
that I worked out together with the
engine is is 65
look at eight five six takes takes
Knight f6 yeah and while when this looks
okay for white absolutely
it's really tough to judge during the
game I mean I saw in the game that I get
this and that he has to give this back
but I couldn't really figure out if this
is good for me or not I mean it look
tempting but I wasn't sure and by the
way there's also the move Bishop takes
h6 in this position that also is
interesting and black is just just about
hanging on here yeah we have to note
that the capture after queen g4 is
immediately design this is also look at
six is the only winning move it's half
of intuitive and yeah Bishop h6 95 same
counter sacrifice takes takes okay for
began its a look yeah it seems to be
enough in this case to - yeah to have a
draw in hand but while it's probably not
better in this in this main line I've
continued this a little bit with the
yeah this and it's really it's such as
long in elegance I mean we had this
position already yeah at the end the
engineer there says white is better
maybe it is but maybe he is but it's
extremely extremely difficult of course
to figure out and in this position
instead of 96 white could also go in
five interesting just saying okay two
pawns I enough and playing 46 after King
G 86 Queen d7
there should be two White has a
tremendous position really for the rook
yeah in those pawns are fat
stick is it enough probably yes I mean
again I've looked at this with the
engine and it has at the end evaluated
this as okay for white and this yeah
enough compensation there are also many
ways to black to go wrong for example if
you can't play play something slower she
looks c8 then after Queen e5 you already
wiped out this is a funny line and rook
takes g7 is absolutely deadly or queen
h5 despite the huge material
disadvantage yeah when I was in the game
I was seeing parts of that I mean as men
you have to be realistic I saw that I
saw up to that justice wrong and cake
cake cake cake cake cake and then I saw
that he has to give it back but that
situation was not clear to me maybe I
should have gone for it simply for the
sake of this being really really cool
and then black has to find it all and
defend this this properly not easy to do
maybe I should have done it and at the
end I was a little bit yeah after I
checked it with with the big engine and
it said ok you could have done it
however what I play it 9f2
Queen back 96 and by the way and there
was also was that here actually on no
window the data and 96 d4 intermediate
move in aged form and we could have gone
to g6 it's not a huge difference again
it's hard for black to not take on a5
and then we get the same position typers
in the game like this and now again
Knight f5 so yeah here black has to take
it's interesting that Queen to f6 loses
immediately due to g5 which is funny I
think somehow after this of this the
Queen is trapped it's really nice and he
has a check we move the king and the
Queen has absolutely no squares
everything is covered pretty nice so
here he was forced to capture the night
and after he takes the e4 square is
clearing oh sorry I didn't want to do
that
sorry good idea we for square is cleared
from my light and you play droopy eight
yeah and now yeah how do you continue in
this position and it's not the position
where you can do something extremely
straightforward however it is clear that
our the pawn and yeah the good square
Ani forms or should be enough
compensation it's often the key is to to
be a bit patient and try to improve a
bit and see if the yeah your opponent
gives you some direct ideas what to do
because I don't have such a direct idea
myself now you can say okay air push the
D pawn also but then has to be prepared
I played King edge one that's not a very
obvious choice maybe the idea of the
movements to play rook g1 and make it
more difficult for him to move the
knight at say to f6
example King edge one let's say you
would play Knight f6 then I go look g1
and the idea is to play g5 and this is
quite annoying that the computer after a
while I mean it already you see it or
anybody to give it more time it will
support this he has to go back actually
and now I've gained a little something
in this procedure yeah note that for
example here I also have g5 as an idea
that's not an easy decision for breccia
the computer is going into this but the
screen as no squares
maybe the computers actually switching
is view after a while and of course they
look very suspicious okay I know it goes
up after a while yeah King h1 Queen is a
group 2 1 is an idea that I'm quite
happy with it irritates black quite a
bit for example here you still cannot go
on I have 622 g5 and this is an
absolutely deadly pin Bishop h6 is in
the mix 94 sorry 94 lie cannot play this
in the game we played Queen to d7 this
is given a questionable sign and black
should in this position and in the next
couple of moves I play now before now he
played rook a7 I probably should be 3 he
should have played 85 in one of the last
couple of moves and here's the last
moment where he has this opportunity you
should absolutely now play a 5 he has to
stop my idea to play before after a 5
and it's not entirely clear how I should
continue and I can go a for completely
blocking the Queen side and say ok long
run I will be able to play h4 and maybe
g5 and I'm the one to play on the Kings
side definitely true I mean this is the
position you're playing for here I would
absolutely never lose because there's no
way black is going to open up the
position in any kind of way if I don't
want to do anything nothing will happen
and it's not necessary either because on
a potential a4i sometimes at any time
it's the case I have deform so
pressurizing c5 and if he takes I take
b6 and I get to protected passes however
the difference is that let's just assume
I'm playing a waiting move and he goes
a4 and they go before in this situation
these pawns are pretty dangerous so I
have to think about this pre
aim pretty hard if I want to allow that
very likely I wouldn't have done that
okay the computer wants to go before my
eggs
b1a if i just take this get this it
would be fine but you already see have
to be three that dennis counter plane
coming i don't know maybe i would have
played a four
I'm not shown what he did and it's
basically losing after f6 the position
that comes from being becomes or
switches from being uncomfortable to
lost because I cannot go before and we
either see five if he does not react to
the move at all one we win or trade be
pawn for the be four point four be six
yeah this is ready to be best but now
after Bishop d6 I'm getting the two
protected not protected but connected
bonds and this will be too strong
there's also still the night stuck in
here on age seven he actually pretty
quickly put this back I just want to be
ready to take the night and I did and
here the points will be decided so
there's really not much that I can do
here Queen c4 at activating pieces the
NTN okay c6 was already winning but I
couldn't quite figure it out yet I mean
I did not like the idea that you might
enter here it's not really a big deal I
have seen G to win but yeah I felt like
why not just take the people that's the
only pawn that with a five therefore
potentially is a danger and I have time
now who create two doesn't really matter
anymore
24 would be two and now these six check
here after Queen to f7 I had to do a bit
of calculation that's really an
important moment now and because after
the trade there is some there's
potential counterclaim with rook edge
area however after c6 I am winning after
Luke h8 wasn't played but in this case I
have whoopty - and now wide Winstead
isn't it because the two points on the
six rank are just too dangerous
after King 8 you have this going here
and then the pawns promote wings the
other line that was important to look at
what the rook see - and now I can play
c7 yeah in this variation
he cannot check me here and after week C
196 and promotion I have a winning
ending and form the tactic
also after c7 group h8 again Jill does
not threaten all that much because of
rooty two other things also will win the
hooptie - its easiest after the trades
he cannot stop the pause oops
the pawns also after c7 he played rock
d7 but now after would be one that would
be 8y just winning that easily so after
this move C resigned the game so I
reasonably happy with this I think I
didn't make any substantial mistake in
this game there was this this
interesting moment here when I could
have sacrificed the night on f7 so we
talking about this moment and I know
maybe I should have done it simply for
the hit yeah because it's nice and I
mean and I saw that it's not totally
ridiculous but I couldn't quite really
figure it out it is good and we also
also you have to keep in mind that the
alternative that I had was leading to
position levels also like here
it was also very nice for white I mean
it's a kind of position can basically
not lose and you have all the chances
them to ya pose problems and I like this
a lot with the 94 and so on it's more of
a strategic solution of course now and I
don't know yeah I'm taking on f7 maybe
maybe I would have done it under other
circumstance so if you have a situation
where you really really really have to
win the game everything else doesn't
count then this is probably an offer you
cannot not refuse entertain on f7 would
have been interesting at least and a
little bit sad that I said didn't do it
but it's I'm at least happy that I saw
the idea and sometimes you are
completely completely surprised once you
look at the game afterwards what what
you miss and I saw the idea of an s held
it could work but couldn't quite bring
myself to play it given that the
alternative was also fairly good um yeah
I hope you enjoyed the video and I
probably will make it his one more video
on games from that from that from that
tournament that was played last week
will be on probably after the weekend on
the weekend I will make more videos have
more time yeah thanks a lot bye bye